let's dive in all right so back in
January Miley Cyrus released her flowers
music video and in it she's wearing the
super flat golden dress but super kind
of closely really kind of resembles the
golden dress that Jayla wore to the 2012
Hunger Games Premiere Miley was
definitely Throwing Shade at j-law by
inferring that she and Liam clap cheeks
while Molly was dating Liam during the
yeah I got that right then on an episode
of Watch What Happens live with Andy
Cohen Andy asked Jayla if she porked
Liam then Jaylon was like honestly dude
no we sucked face one time and that was
after they broke up and she was like
super casual about it just like laughing
it off like oh my God now people think
that cleared it up but here at Hawk off
Studios we think that sounds pretty G
dang suspicious I'm looking at you Jayla
and Liam I'm looking at you Playboy plus
we all know that kiss one time is
Hollywood speak
either way I'm stoked for Miley she's an
empowered Queen Jayla stoked for her
she's a fantastic actress and Liam is
super in shape so what do you guys think
is the real story